si ya no la más zona llegarán los
vacunos y se va a comenzar a vacunar a
las personas que están en situación de
riesgo así como profesional de salud de
ancianos mayores de 75 años y otros
grupos de riesgo
pero en este momento o en este estado la
preocupación mayor es por las camas de
hospital y la falta de oxígeno que se
necesita más en este momento y cuál es
el reporte de la emergencia
si la situación en el amazon es más
complicada por las diferentes
situaciones de vulnerabilidad que tiene
el amazonas con votar las grandes
distancias la concentración de unidades
de complejidad solamente en la capital
del estado que ha organizado más o menos
del 97 por ciento de la ocupación de
estas unidades en el municipio entonces
hubo una escasez de oxígeno y hubo unos
últimos días falta de auxilio y un
movimiento grande para poder conseguir
ese oxígeno de otros estados y como
estado hablando hasta de otros países